bon
[Musique]
alban il avait 4 ans on était en
décembre 2015 puis garçon qui pétait la
forme ils étaient en moyenne section
je suis sa maman et allemands en fait
c'était plus allemand il avait une
attitude et son corps ne le tenait plus
il était chief molle est ici plus vivant
en fait à l'intérieur de son corps du
tout j'avoue jeunes qui rentraient de
l'école il souffrait mal au dos mal au
ventre et donc j'appelle le 15 une fois
deux fois trois fois et on part avec un
sac complet fait le doudou sommes partis
d'abord aux urgences du chu qui plus est
dernier du tour fallait rentrer et donc
se finit par faire une prise de sang une
deuxième une troisième est là en milieu
de nuit on me dit avec lui on va
peut-être vous garder parce qu'on a
trouvé des blast dans le sang est en
fait les blast c'est les premières
cellules cancéreuses en
est là on épure partie où vous lâche
plus en fait vous rentrez vous ressortez
pas
[Musique]
oh
ça faisait quelques jours qui se
plaignait des gens qui boitait et un
soir une fait la température comme ça le
lendemain du coup je consulte est en
fait le lundi c'était pas mieux donc le
médecin a prise de sang et c'est là que
ça commençait et au final la prise de
sang a révélé une leucémie ils ont tout
de suite vu que c'était à la forme de
beurre guide donc cancer des globules
blancs ma fille se plaignait beaucoup du
ventre s'est aperçue qu'elle avait une
masse de 12 centimètres sur 7 enroulée
autour d'un ovaire s'est fait tout
enlever et la masse l'ovaire la trompe
et un an après il ya une récidive donc
sur l'autre au vert donc ils ont réussi
à le garder sont ouverts par contre elle
a eu de la chimio pendant pendant six
mois c'est tout qui changent du jour au
lendemain et il n'y a pas le temps de
dire où on y va c'est parti
[Musique]
un
enfant qui déclarent un cancer c'est un
enfant qu'on ne sait pas si lendemain et
surlendemain trois mois après six mois a
presque envie donc on commence déjà à
penser que son enfant ne sera
potentiellement mort dans quelques
semaines quelques mois et puis lé
traitement mais il ya les effets
secondaires des traitements que malone
une des chimiothérapies lui a provoqué
des neuropathies des membres notamment
des membres à des membres inférieurs ce
qui lui a provoqué de la paire fin
passagère de la marche il a perdu trois
ans on joue la part du 22 kg et avec
quand même
pas mal de soucis médicaux parce qu'ils
ont c'est que la fin d'un tortueux et
des années de traitement avec des
chimiothérapies quotidienne avec des
injections d injection qui sont en intra
tkl des fonctions des ponctions
lombaires des fonctions de moelle
osseuse on passe pas au bloc opératoire
quand on est un enfant pour faire tout
ça donc là je sais pas si vous imaginez
la longueur des aiguilles à ponctionner
moi j'aurais voulu prendre tout ça à son
âge on n'est pas censé vivre ça
c'est
cesser à 300 ce qu'on leur injecte dans
leur corps effectivement on leur injecte
du poison pour tuer un poison en plus
des corticoïdes parce qu'ils ont des
corticoïdes à haute dose qui provoque un
gonflement du visage du ventre des
douleurs musculaires importante à type
courbatures mais vraiment intense
malone a été mis sous morphine pour
pallier à ces douleurs la perte des
cheveux les autres sessions alimentaires
la baisse de moral malone a eu des
passages de dépression moi ma fille m'a
dit de toute façon si ça venait à
revenir je ne ferai pas de chimio et si
je dois mourir je mourrai
c'est lourd pour un enfant de 4 ans et
on est parent et on est à côté tout ça
bah c'est finalement en fin de en fin de
traitement de baptiste qui se passait
pas de trois mois sans clients nouveaux
cas et là ça commençait à
commencer à trotter dans la tête mais
qu'est ce qui se passe sur le secteur où
on est sur
cette nuit commune
qui partent d'une sainte pazanne qui
correspond à un petit peu si vous avez
une carte géographique comme un
épicentre avec huit enfants qui ont
déclaré un cancer depuis 2015 est ce
qu'on parle bien depuis 2015 puisque
avant y'avait pas de concert d'enfants
répertoriés réellement sur le secteur et
qu'on n'arrive pas à voir les chiffres
si on trace
finalement un cercle de 15 kilomètres de
rayon autour de notre maison on va
trouver les 25 les 25 26
enfants malades depuis depuis cinq ans
on est au mois d'août 2021 et
et on connaît les 25 enfants il y en a
sept qui sont morts
alors les cancers pédiatriques ça
représente environ 2500 cas qui sont qui
sont diagnostiqués
par an avec des cancers qui sont plus
dominants comme les leucémies comme les
cancers du système nerveux central après
cause des cancers pédiatriques elles
sont elles sont très mal connus à ce
jour
les hypothèses sont sont des causes qui
skie
plurifactoriels donc ça peut être des
causes génétiques des facteurs
environnementaux ou des facteurs
également qui seraient liés à des
infections d exposition aux pesticides
pendant la grossesse ou les expositions
pesticides voilà dans les usages
domestiques les expositions aux champs
électromagnétiques basses fréquences
donc là on est quand même si tu es en
campagne donc il ya énormément de
pesticides on est quand même entourée de
terrains agricoles les terres les
failles enfin bon on peut tout imaginer
aller les éoliennes qui sont pas loin il
ya tellement de choses autour de nous
l'air qu'on respire enfin qu'est ce que
c'est compliqué à savoir d'où ça vient
[Musique]
on
il s'est exercé des missions de veille
elle exerce aussi des missions de
contrôle et de gestion des risques sur
certains milieux et également et elle
est porteuse de politiques de prévention
et de promotion de la santé elle a fait
une évaluation de voilà et ce n'était
pas un excès d'un excès de cas voilà
elle a conclu à un accepta par rapport à
ce qu'on avait pu observer
antérieurement sur sur scène clown à
second signalement d'un particulier en
2019 avec trois nouveaux cas de leucémie
l'a conduit la rs ajustements sollicité
l'expertisé de santé publique france
pour pour que soit réalisée une enquête
une enquête épidémiologique
donc on tourne à une signalement de
suspicion de ce qu'on appelle un agrégat
de deux cas d'un concept électrique
comme on utilise souvent un anglicisme
cluster mais c'est un agrégat d'un
regroupement tambre spatial non
seulement à l'échelle locale en fait il
existe un guide et les dommages qu'ont
emploi c'est de répondre à deux
questions c'est premièrement esker on
peut observer et
confirmé qu'il existe que cet excès de
maladie dans le territoire qui nous est
finale et les deuxièmes ancien arrivent
à l'heure l'objectiver est ce que l'on
est capable de trouver la présence d'une
exposition inhabituelle à l'échelle
locale de cette population et que c'est
qu'on n'a plus qu'à savoir en
2019 avec deux fois plus de cas observé
qu attendu en fait quand on l'a fait
l'étude plus complète de cartographie en
2020 ou en a remis en perspective le
fait afin de pas mal avec tout le
département on n'a pas retrouvé cette
excuse santé publique france n'avait
identifiez pas de source commune
d'exposition donc neuro commandé par la
conformer mais voilà où guînes de
poursuivre en fait les investigations on
en était arrivé à la limite de ce qu'on
pouvait faire donc on a dû passer le
mois à la recherche à 7 t part à ces
moments là est en fait en or il nous
faut des des études leurs valeurs
nationales avec des centaines voire des
milliers d'enfants concernés pour
pouvoir mettre en évidence quelque chose
et le jour où c'est qu'on sent mieux
compris mais quand nous on va pouvoir
labour et des outils mu adapté pour les
chaînes locales pour nous pouvons mieux
répondre aux questions extrêmement
pertinent des familles explique pourquoi
je pense que ça a été sans doute très
court aussi un peu difficile pour les
pour pour les familles d'entendre le
fait que finalement rien ne distinguait
ça ne pas aller en terme de forme et
wassa pédiatrique le reste du
département nous sommes passés dans une
colère
une grosse colère pourquoi lui
aujourd'hui il y en a d'autres
malheureusement je me sent incomprise
pas soutenu ils savent qu'il se passe
quelque chose ils ne font rien ça
continue d'autres cas se déclarent
d'autres enfants décèdent quoi ça tombe
tout le temps tous les six mois il n'y a
pas un gamin qui malade moi je les
invite à venir découvrir notre quotidien
accompagnez nos enfants se faire poser
une chimiothérapie
avoir un enfant en face de vous vous
dites que c'est votre enfant mais vous
le reconnaissez même pas tellement les
traitements les abîmes et je trouve ça
inadmissible de de savoir des choses est
de laisser les choses se faire il n'y a
pas d'implications des régions pays de
la loire jusqu alors ça va pas dire ça
va pas changer fait les élus renvoi mais
ya pas de clusters
les autorités sanitaires ont été alertés
elles disent qui a rien d'autre à faire
donc nous c'est pas notre compétence
donc en fait c'est la compétence de qui
donc les élus c'est pas leurs
compétences
les autorités sanitaires c'est pas leurs
compétences non plus donc il reste que
les parents ont fait moi je reste
persuadé aujourd'hui que le poison il
toujours là il est toujours là on l'a
pas trouvée parce qu'on n'a peut-être
pas
[Musique]
approfondie certaines analyses peut-être
que leur méthodologie actuelle ne
fonctionne pas suffisamment mais il ya
quelque chose à faire
[Musique]
qu'on a fait des analyses
effectivement dans les cheveux des
enfants on a fait des analyses de l'eau
analyse dans l'air intérieur également
de domicile et à chaque fois on a trouvé
des éléments donc on a trouvé
effectivement dans les produits
phytosanitaires des choses qui convenait
pas on a trouvé donc dans l'analyse de
l'air intérieur des domiciles des
produits qui n'ont rien à voir avec ce
qui pourrait être utilisé dans une
maison et puis on a trouvé voilà des
métaux les métaux qu'est ce qu'ils ont à
faire dans le corps des enfants c'est
pareil
on a trouvé des champs
électromagnétiques
au delà des normes
le collectif à un moment donné bien
gharbi a pris conscience qu'à un moment
donné parce que je ne pourrais pas
répondre alors à leurs attentes on n'est
pas toujours en phase mais on n'exclut
pas de le regarder ces résultats des
initiatives
donc point de vue d'instituer nous
serons des démarches scientifiques et
pousse ses jo derrière qui sont basés
beaucoup cela d'être un tueur et sur
l'un des expériences nationales et on se
contourne quelque part de ses démarches
on a toujours l'impression même quand
les choses peuvent se faire qui a un
empêchement qu'elle puisse se mettre en
place un empêchement qu'on ait des
résultats et quand bien même on a des
résultats qu on les transmet on dit mais
regardez quand on cherche un tout petit
peu chaque fois en trouvant des éléments
inquiétants silva pas eu le collectif
on aura aucune idée du nombre de cancers
évidemment ici dans les 10 km dans le
rayon de 10 km autour de cinq personnes
est ce que c'est quelque chose qu'on ne
veut pas dire à la population pour pas
effrayer ça ne pas anne est-ce que c'est
justement pour pas faire fuir cette
population est ce qu'on veut cacher ce
qu'on veut nous cacher quelque chose il
n'y a pas de transparence sur
sur les données relatives aux cancers ou
d'être lourd qu'il avait aucune volonté
de vos investigations environnementales
de dodo caché que de cacher quoi que ce
soit enfin voila on doit respecter
certains contraintes scientifiques qui
sont d'auckland précédé ça fait beaucoup
de deux bars dans la presse de disco
qu'on essaie de dissimuler des choses de
deniers leurs invités mais en fait c'est
pas du tout le cas
[Musique]
c'est quoi la santé environnementale
c'est l'impact de l'homme sur
l'environnement faune et flore et les
conséquences pas sur sa santé celle de
tous les êtres vivants tu sais tu pas un
sujet qui est porté politiquement
d'ailleurs il ya qu'il ya de quoi être
un petit peu déçu quand je me suis
engagé auprès d'emmanuel macron quand il
était candidat dans son programme il y
avait vraiment un sujet sur la santé
environnementale
mais aujourd'hui on n'a pas beaucoup
travaillé là-dessus l'hôpital et clé de
voûte de aujourd'hui notre système de
santé la prévention la recherche sont
vraiment on est à l'âge de pierre dans
ce domaine là on sait bien soigner les
maladies en france mais malheureusement
fait beaucoup moins de préventif et si
on prenait les choses dans l'autre sens
qu on la pense en termes de prévention
c'est vraiment on descendre des seaux
redescend on va aux racines et on
regarde il regarde ce qui se passe nous
faut accepter de regarder là c'est
vraiment tout un système de pensée qui
est à revoir il faut arrêter de
stigmatiser par exemple les agriculteurs
ou les industriels ou où les élus qu'il
faut travailler sur les territoires on
l'entend on va reparler de transition
nous on a raté une marche il fallait
passer par la médiation avec esprit
culteurs les industriels les élus les
associations les citoyens le citoyen
fait la première personne concernée on
voit que les individus s'interroge sur
l'environnement dans lequel les
habitants mettent au monde leur enfant
et pour moi c'est une bonne chose parce
que ça mobilise les élus se mobilisent
des pouvoirs publics et ça peut donner
un coup de vent coup de pouce aux
efforts et on est toujours
partons pour que des citoyens engagés
participent aux travaux on cherche pas
pour incriminer pas pour aller taper sur
la tête des uns et des autres non on
cherche simplement parce que c'est c'est
protéger les enfants après et puis on
accompagne derrière il faut que ça soit
fait par les élus tout ça faut que ça
soit fait par l'état ont pour l'heure
pour avoir un changement de pratique ou
un changement de l'environnement s'il ya
des choses à changer donc on dit pas
tout seul
[Musique]